[Music]
um
40 minutes before the show merch you
were on your way here and virgin starts
laughing goes no way
we still milking the dead vampire son
Kevin is he still glamming us it's
doubling down
by the way I want to thank everybody who
have been going to that channel I've
been reading some of the comments and
you guys have been [ __ ] holy like
what a bunch of [ __ ] ghouls yeah tell
people
listening and watching a little what we
were talking to the crew about though
you and I had had some foreplay over the
last four years about
reclaiming each other they're glamming
each other they're giving each other
Glam jobs seriously podcast oh yeah
there's really one person who made this
podcast happened with Vince McMahon he
was so gorgeous he was beautiful a lot
of people come together to make it
happen but yeah to actually make no to
Kevin and I take it seriously and buckle
down so but my you know my son
uh floated into the room as if not even
making a step and he he said to me
Father
why don't you have a hundred thousand
Subs yet I don't know why he speaks like
a [ __ ] weird ghost from the 50s
that's fennel people on the YouTube in
the in the TV room on the smart
television
you they're all smart televisions Now
Kevin I know you're a stupid wrestler
[ __ ] brain damaged idiot who never
really [ __ ] lifted a finger in the
ring I know you're a dumb lazy [ __ ]
lunk head but all TVs are smart TVs now
I couldn't even but I was looking at TVs
I was the only reason I bought a TV was
because how cheap the smart TVs they're
all smart TVs just plug them in if you
go to like stay at an Airbnb and they
have an old TV [ __ ] complain I'm
amazing about the smart TV I was saying
this morning because I just used the the
big TV in this room as a monitor for my
computer but it's a smart TV turn it on
it's like oh you want to use Roku you
want to go to Samsung's TV app I don't
want any of that get
my son's
plethora of
podcasts that he watches
and he would he would always say Dad
Kevin do you know what the plethora is
he was a big fan of the show called
Revenge of the Sith I love that show
we're gonna watch his dad watch us so I
finally I sat down I watched Tom seguro
with him
is that what killed them
and uh
actually the the one that I saw I think
was jeselnek was the uh
was the host was the guest hey can you
get to it please Anthony Justin we know
oh we know it wasn't we know what we
know it wasn't Walton jeselnick Tom Tom
Segura and uh Jesse okay we'll go on
there
you just will not keep us to guess I
know and it was on the Tom Segura
program okay with uh I think it was
Anthony Jeselnik yeah I know you said
it's so gorgeous
caught segor was Glam in me I said was
Amy Schumer Glam in you
back in the day the Gaston it was it was
good and then it was like it was well
and I watched some crystallia he's a
little bit he's oh yeah Tristan Ash was
a big crystalia guy so wait this guy
just [ __ ] liked all the West Coast
podcasters basically
uh apparently he just kind of he had a
playlist on it just said rapist
just all these California guys
he didn't have an M impression I think
man you know I saw this um
trash Tuesday oh man and uh I gotta say
man I saw this Esther povitsky girl on
there I haven't seen somebody with less
of a work rate than me in WCW I mean
this chick shows up gets paid no sells
just sidewalk slam big boot hair flip go
home cash your check man
I think we have a similar sense of humor
God he's dead he's hard his son is no
longer in this plane of existence
because of certain things that he put in
his body yeah that's that's I was very
careful
I don't care anymore
just saying certain things that he put
in his body used by your own admission
now everyone has different theories as
to which substances did what but you
know hey something happened and here we
are
um
fauci gave a retirement speech today
and then by the way it's not gorgeous
anymore now he's at that point now where
the skin is still on but it kind of
looks like wax paper okay
come on
watch different people hey man don't do
that don't use don't stand on his dead
son to get us views that's his job yeah
no I'm sorry I don't want to get in your
way of a hundred thousand views yeah
yeah you might get a banned from Twitter
you know I said Dad this is something
also I don't stand on a corpse the goop
will come out okay well now I know that
I didn't know that you do
I'm just filming I'm just filming
funerals where the body flies out guys
if I don't have a plaque to put my son's
ashes next to a man it's gonna be real
sad they think I'm just some dumb heck
you have you know comedic timing and you
you know a little bit about you know
enough you know enough about enough
things to piss people off
you know you should say you know so you
know
the mental roadblock that you're [ __ ]
hitting trying to get through this
goddamn statement that's taking you
[ __ ] 10 times longer than it should
is the last semblance of a [ __ ]
conscience you have left please God
listen to it
we never need to uh
I'm talking with Sean and I that we
never need to talk about anything about
um
how how oil gets to our country because
we have no idea on Supply
I he said Gee dude Kevin Nash has become
a [ __ ] drunk there's no way around it
it's either drinking or pills because he
used to be pretty sharp right remember
the old Sean Hall uh Sean Oliver [ __ ]
Kevin Nash was like the best [ __ ] on the
internet was was whenever they got
together and did their little [ __ ]
you shoots and stuff but he's like
frogging
you know I mean I'm sure he's also
medicating himself even extra now that
his kid died too that's pretty that's
part of it yeah but the thing is is he
said we quit drinking cold turkey
together
oh yeah me and my son man we quit
drinking cold turkey together man then
why did you sound drunk in the [ __ ]
click this episodes when he was alive he
always sounds like he's [ __ ] so maybe
you quit drinking but then he even still
got my son quit drinking but the doctor
had us on benzos which is [ __ ] worse
than drinking yeah I I literally was
just about to say this looks like benzos
to me
the information is not available out
there anyway so no no so we can't read
about it or anything yeah yeah yeah so
it's just it's it's such a
such a mystery
but anyway he so we will you're right
because honestly like there's a reason I
don't like to use benzos
um even though I could easily get them
prescribed it's just because I only need
to take a Xanax maybe four times a year
I think you're in the kind of the same
boat right yeah or like once Blue Moon
maybe if you're really having a bad
[ __ ] but like for the most part it's
when you fly or I don't need that much
around me but I could drink and do a
show I can smoke weed and do insurance
so many things I could I could eat
shrooms and do a [ __ ] show but Ben
listen to one of our riffs
is a [ __ ] weird one man because it
does make you slurry and it makes you
tired but Russell vouch for the it does
something to your brain where it just
blocks everything out good and bad yeah
zombie zombie fight you become zombified
I remember like when I was 19 and I went
in there I have some anxiety in my
doctor by the way not like a just my my
general doctor prescribed to me this is
not a joke Zoloft Klonopin and Xanax at
the same time
19. instead of even going like hey man
you'll get out you'll be all right or
just whatever hey it was just like here
you go here's draw bro I would sleep
like 12 hours a day I was a zombie when
I was up I didn't feel happiness or
sadness I was just [ __ ] gone see I
had a better doctor when I was younger
when I got prescribed Xanax back in the
day he like I had the opposite kind of
doctor they prescribed me very little a
little very little bit of Xanax and they
told me only when you're having an acute
panic attack this is not to be taken for
[ __ ] cute when I have a panic attack
because he's like this is not to be
taken daily
I'm freaking out I was told it was not
to be taken daily it was not to be taken
as a crutch for me get through a tough
day it was between taken when you're
like when you get the breathing thing
and you start going
yeah and then you take he said then take
one and go lay down and just [ __ ] sit
for a half hour because Xanax is best
used when you like are legit like I'm
having a heart attack yeah when you're
like oh God I'm going to die
yeah because if you take a Xanax and
you're still having a heart attack then
you can call a [ __ ] ambulance I'm
having a heart attack
I put a Xanax cringe compilation in the
Show links thank you well let's finish
this Xanax cringe [ __ ] compilation
hey hey hey don't talk about our show
that way
and I said you know what I said
yeah I should but I said I do it but I I
I've had to actually the only person oh
Fergie I think I got like that
yeah because this is I know the working
in strip clubs for years I know and you
know what I've taken a bottle he's
taking a bar that's a bar probably on it
because he's a big boy yeah he's a big
guy he's got to be a bar and it's
probably tolerance is pretty high you
gotta think the literal method of action
for Xanax is it depresses your nervous
system well this [ __ ] this entire
Show's depressing my nervous system the
thing is alcohol does that too it just
doesn't do it as [ __ ] effectively you
know what I mean yeah
can you put it at .75 speed I'm just I'm
so curious
George would be shot
called shots
we talked
do the opposite put it at one five and
see if it sounds normal okay
and they sent us like they
Sean and I talked actually he's on coke
no here we go
I bet you'll do one two five is what he
used to talk like
you can take it from there
well then we had to once we decided we
were going to do it we had to we had to
shop it around
we had to find people willing to I think
I'm gonna leave it at one two five every
time we cover them except this pitch
it's gonna be whatever we want to talk
about
so what's the SL what's the angle of it
whatever we want to talk about yeah it's
a show about nothing go watch old
go watch us together on old videos
you'll understand and very quickly I
mean I didn't have to even explain to
Conrad got it right away and was like
done you know and uh so don't forget to
go to save for camera.com if you go
right now to save the car right okay
man one of the funnier tweets
when CM Punk had that whole blowout with
aw it was somebody tweeted out like uh
hey this is Conrad Thompson and you're
listening to best in the world with CM
Punk okay see him chat me up on this
come upstairs and
yeah look at Czechoslovakia so none of
this had to do with Justin they just
clicked there and I saw people you
talked about Trista for four seconds and
then they clicked and then it's Xanax of
course he's now he's click baiting his
son for views
bro
whatever
because they saw it out of a bad
situation they saw the engagement they
got versus the other videos yep you're
right whenever they're sitting around
talking about Trump and [ __ ] nobody
cares they saw the engagement and
they're both they've both convinced
themselves hey we're doing this to honor
Tristan's memory he would have wanted
this but deep down it's the truth is
you just want to make money off this